my three girls went to school with kobe
bryant's daughters and they played
multiple sports with them in my
experience I have to say that Kobe
Bryant was one of the most amazing dads
he was at school you know before school
was out picking his kids up he
volunteered to file library books back
he would serve hot lunch he coached the
girls in basketball and he was at all
the picnics and the shows and
videotaping his girls and I know that at
one point their girls were all in a
volleyball club and there was one place
that doesn't even have bleachers and you
had to sit there each chair all day but
he'd be sitting in a beach chair
watching his kids it's just a really
devoted father and his family was his
first priority and it was so clear and I
think that's just an amazing aspect of
him I mean everyone knows it was an
amazing athlete and he was a
philanthropist and he gave back so much
but he really he put his family first
but my daughter Sophie was coached by
him uh you know during the summer he
coached the girls and it was cute as she
made varsity vascular varsity basketball
team as a starter as a freshman in high
school so when he saw her after that
he'd come in nickname for varsity so
that was cutie say hey varsity that's
she she really appreciated that and I
you know I have to tell you I'm Stella
and Adeline are also basketball players
and they played in the same age group as
Gianna and there was a final game and
for the championship and Stella and our
lice he was playing Kobe Brian's team
and right before the clock went out
Stella
threw a three-pointer that was beyond
half-court and she made it and it went
in swish and it was the cutest thing
here we're playing against his team and
he was so proud of her he came out into
the middle of the court and gave her a
hug and that's just what a good guy he
was he just saw that I was an amazing
shot he was gonna come and congratulate
Stella even though it was against his
team
it's just really such a great kind heart
the whole community were just it's it's
like it's been a bad dream and it's a
you know that they had a vigil last
night both at their school and and also
in the community and so they were there
and you know it's it's just I don't know
I I'm in North Carolina right now and I
I see people that are just in tears
walking around here it's just it's just
such a tragedy for so many families
Christina Mauser was an amazing
basketball coach she coached all three
of my girls in middle school and they
created such develops to bond with her
and she was so good to the girls and
I've just really made things for a great
experience for all three of my kids
really good woman and even when Kobe was
coaching the kids during you know middle
school and when girls were were younger
he was always working with Christina
Mouser so she worked with him for a long
time I have to say that tear bugs it's
all it was everything was about their
family I mean Christina was a great worm
of three children she has an amazing
husband and you know they just had had a
great family and and Cohiba same there
they were they were parents the family
restaurant
[Music]
you